Before we go any further.
It would be great if our view controller
where the recording happens was called
something other than
just view controller.
In writing your app,
there are times when you might
want to rename your classes.
And it takes just a minute.
Let me show you.
To rename our view controller,
we're going to do three steps.
We want to change the name
of the view controller
to Record Sounds View Controller.
First, in the project navigator S=select
a viewcontroller.swift file and
single click.
Change the name to record
sounds view controller.
Open the class we just renamed and
change the name in the comments and
in the class decoration to
record sounds view controller.
You can press command
s to save this file.
One last step, we have to tell the
main.storyboard that the view controller
for this view, is no longer
called ViewController.swift, but
it's now called
RecordSoundsViewController.
Open the main.storyboards file and
select a view controller for
a first view.
Switch to the identity inspector and
change its name to
RecordSoundsViewController.
Press return to make this take effect,
that's all it takes to
change in name of a class.
Next, let's add the AV audio
recorder code you saw earlier.